يعمل بورتر من الرئيس المصري عبد
السيسي على مساعدته على البقاء في
السلطة لفترة أطول ،
ومن المتوقع أن لا يكون البرلمان المصري اليوم من خلال إجراء تغييرات على
الدستور يمهد الطريق لأن السيسي
للبقاء في السلطة حتى عام 2030 لأن مصر
لا تزال بحاجة إلى إجراء استفتاء لوضع
اللمسات الأخيرة على الدستور.  يقول مؤيدو
السلطة القضائية إن هذه الخطوة ستمنحه أيضًا سيطرة أكبر على السلطة القضائية
، وهي ضرورية لتحقيق الاستقرار
ومنح السيسي مزيدًا من الوقت لتنفيذ
الإصلاحات الاقتصادية ، لكن النقاد يحذرون من أن
البلاد بالفعل تمارس الاستبداد.
تغيير كبير ،
أليس كذلك ، وهو هل عاد هارت
إلى العصور السابقة ، هذا صحيح؟ الكثير من
الناس عندما ترى ما يقولونه
عن هذا في مصر يقولون إن هذا
يذكرنا بأيام مبارك حيث كان
ذلك الرئيس الذي كان
رئاسيًا.  المنزل في عام 2011 قد قضى
ما يقرب من ثلاثة عقود يقولون إن هذا
مجرد تعيين الرئيس السيسي
لجولة مماثلة فهو يبلغ من العمر 64 عامًا وإذا كان
هذا التعديل  يمر ، ثم
يمكن أن يصبح رئيسًا حتى
يبلغ من العمر 80 عامًا تقريبًا ، لذا يعد هذا تغييرًا مهمًا
في الدستور إذا تم ذلك
وتمت الموافقة عليه من خلال استفتاء وطني ،
وهناك أيضًا تغيير آخر
في هذا التعديل الدستوري الذي من
شأنه أن يمنح الجيش المصري مزيدًا من
السلطة في  الدولة وعلينا أن
نتذكر أن الجيش لعب
دورًا حاسمًا في ثورة 2011 في
الانقلاب الشعبي عام 2013 ، ولذا فإن هذا التعديل
الجديد سيمنحهم مكانة أكبر
داخل الدولة الآن يقول الناس أن
مؤيديها أن هذا هو جلب
الاستقرار والأمن اللذان
تحتاجهما مصر بشدة في ديسمبر / كانون الأول الماضي فقط
للسائحين الذين قُتلوا عندما انفجرت قنبلة على جانب الطريق
بجوار الحافلة السياحية
بجوار أهرامات الجيزة ، لكن
المنتقدين يقولون إن هذه مجرد
خطوة أخرى نحو الاستبداد ، ومن
المثير للاهتمام ملاحظة ذلك في السابق
في مقابلات مع رئيس الإعلام الدولي
السيسي قال إنه لا
ينوي البقاء لفترة أطول لذلك
سنرى  إذا كان لا يزال يدير ، فأنت تعلم أنه على
الرغم من
قيامهم بهذه التغييرات ، فلا يزال يتعين عليه
الترشح ، ولكن إذا نظرت إلى الوراء في
الانتخابات الرئاسية الأخيرة في العام الماضي عندما
كان هناك أشخاص خاضوا ضدهم ،
فقد انسحب جميع المنافسين الرئيسيين
إما تم القبض عليهم أو من خلال
التخويف و  الخوف وهكذا
حقق الرئيس نصرًا ساحقًا في
التسعينيات ولهذا السبب يقول الناس أن
هذا ليس تحركًا نحو الديمقراطية
بل بالأحرى أعمال استبدادية